magath à gazaupouy à garder ou donner
vous être coupée en deux ce soir en
direct sur ces huit dans la magie selon
geri et vous l'avez bien répéter ce que
l'afld a répété on l'a vu face à et
kelly ma compagne a battu à braga
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ici on est de retour la grande scène
alors ça c'est un détour les plus
mythiques de la prestidigitation la
femme coupée en deux mais attention
version john cooper a bien sûr d'abord
et encore évidemment c'est une belle
s'était extrait ça c'est toi monsieur
afin que je déteste ça je sais c'est
pour ça qu'on vous la proposer vous
inquiétez pas régate tchador c'est tout
allez tu sors bien ce métier et je fais
quoi et tu ta sale qui reçoit ici up et
tu t'installes tranquillement j'ai
maintenant stable ouais c'est comme à la
maison est ce que je te donne micro
malaise possible ah oui c'est ça tu te
sens à l'aise voilà très bien aller vite
elle se met bien vous avez l'air un peu
stressé à gaz avait des bals et c'est
très bien après jean on va essayer de la
faire couper en deux commencez ici
regardez on a du matériel transparent et
je vais tenter vous les placez votre
mine à l'intérieur laquelle est assez
solide avant assez solide je suis pas
étrangler pas maxime attention c'est mal
et c'est ma demie c'est ma demie mais
bon mais non il va mais non plus alors
vous êtes entraîné maxime je me souviens
c'est bonjour excusez moi je vous êtes
vous inquiétez pas ce qu'il fallait pas
l'art vous max et moi non mais c'est en
parle pas gâcher
les recherches et les lames les la
tournée continue vous placer en dessous
on enchaîne les aces qui est ce qu'il ya
des pompiers je suis pas malade il a
toujours vous inquiétez pas elle fait ce
pompier c'est bon allez on tourne on est
bien et maintenant on va sur cd l'année
2,7 à leurs noms mais des vrais
faites attention agatha mais oui si tu
reviens mais n'en attends attends
attends c'est agathe c'est quoi je vais
mettre la première lame mais qu'elle n'a
pas dit arrête tes conneries
j'ai l'habitude dossier du métier entre
montre la voie c'est comme ça voilà
allez vous les placez attention à mon
attention
c'est bloqué ça va ça va et plus
compliqué c'est ce pas ce gars est la
seconde lame royal et la tête alouette à
force j'ai une petite technique regard
des 1 2
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes très bas 3 2 1 c'est parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais vous êtes bien dans cette position
parce que la médecine locale moi tout de
suite ça n'attend juste à vous féliciter
maxime merci kelly prince et tout ça
fait toujours bien
shogun 2 mai john dragani compte bien ne
pas surtout où les consignes juin peut
être à bientôt
comment liste non bon allez moi j'ai de
la peine non mais oui alors la rougeole
et on tape mais ça n'a jamais foiré ce
truc maintenant au pied du bâton vous
parler c'est essentiel c'est parti sa
coupe en deux la suite à léonie barreaux
c'est parti on retiendra tout ça on
essaie de bien les voilà bien sûr il
faut vraiment que le buste soit raccord
avec leurs élèves les bars peut-être que
tu es moi et s'il ya du sang s'il ya du
son est non non c'est bon je me sens
déjà que mieux vaut qu'elle est un peu
mieux un peu mieux
y at il des quotas
[Applaudissements]
vaut mieux elle va venir dans les
sketchs locaux 6 et ie pas ses pieds bon
bah quand même te défaire ckoi deux
trous de mémoire par moments est-ce que
agathe bête pourquoi situer la réponse
tout de suite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]